Bad news for Ukraine.
Slovakia looks to become the latest European nation to
end military aid to the country.
The trigger for this move
was Slovakia's recent election,
where the left wing
populist party of former Prime Minister Robert Fiko
came out on top with 23.3% of the votes,
edging out the current centrist government at 17%,
even though no party scored an outright majority
because party gets the first shot
at forming a coalition government.
This is big stuff.
A speaker was promised that Slovakia will
not send a single round of ammunition to Ukraine
and has called for better relations with Russia.
Now you might remember Slovakia
as one of Ukraine's biggest supporters
since the Russian invasion began,
but if he could takes the home,
experts are saying
Slovakia could start leaning towards an anti EU,
anti native foreign policy camp,
joining others like Hungary and Poland.
This is a big deal
because it's likely to throw wrench in Ukraine's war
efforts against Russia
and shake up the unity of the entire European Union.
Tough times ahead for Ukraine.